[Musique]
alors
et
m
[Musique]
et
chaque matin
on part avec notre vélo cargo et on va
faire le tour des magasins pour récolter
le marc de café
donc on fait 15 km par jour avec jusqu'à
parfois 100 kg de café récoltés par jour
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hopper
il ya 15000 tonnes de marc de café par
an à bruxelles c'est difficile à
imaginer chiffres c'est juste énorme et
ce marc de café s'il est mieux même
endroit il est acide il détruit et
détruit les sols est donc vide et c'est
de récupérer ce qui peut avoir toute une
série de qualités pour faire quelque
chose en fait c'est comme dans la nature
par nature ya pas de déchets le déchet
c'est une invention humaine donc chaque
mois on va produire à une tonne de
champignons qu'on va accueillir tous les
matins pour qu'ils soient le plus frais
possible et on parlait livrer à nos
partenaires qui sont des magasins bio ou
qui sont des restaurants
alors me demande souvent si le
champignon empêche de dormir aussi de la
caféine dedans et en fait c'est ça la
magie du champignon c'est un renne
particulier dans les êtres vivants et le
champignon est capable de dégrader le
marc de café ils vont pas de café
unicopa du marc de café
il voit de l'azoté de l'hydrogène et de
l'oxygène du carbone et il va utiliser
cette base pour tirer juste ce dont il a
besoin
[Musique]
don
oui
[Musique]